all right in our first news story today
shockingly
according to bloomberg zillow has paused
their eye buying business and is trying
to unload 7 000 homes to institutional
investors for 2.8 billion zillow shares
got decimated it's down eleven point
five percent on the news dropping to
eighty five dollars a share they lost
two billion dollars in market cap uh and
zillow is going to reduce its workforce
by 25
over
the next few months so let's
unpack what i buying is if you haven't
heard this term it's an industry term in
real estate basically means
that a bunch of
these websites that like redfin and
zillow would buy homes to flip them
just institutionalized buying of homes
single-family homes specifically
so
zillow ramped this up
after buying about 700 homes in 2018 uh
of course there is the company open door
uh that keith for boyfriend of the pod
founded and that went public ipob was uh
open door really clever idea i had keith
boy to talk about that company years ago
on the pod zillow offers homeowners the
ability to request an offer on their
house
then they use an algorithm to generate
the price
if that price is accepted zillow sends
an inspector to confirm the status of
the home zillow pays in cash uh if the
inspection checks out and then they make
repairs and put the property back on the
market and they were targeting like four
or five percent at scale uh obviously as
i said redfin and open door have similar
programs but on october 18th zillow put
out a statement that zillow offers would
not be buying any more homes in 2021
they said quote due to a backlog in
renovations and operational capacity
constraints they were going to stop the
program in other words
they bought homes that needed
renovations
and uh
operational capacity to me means they
weren't executing at a high level
and i heard this from the grapevine
that
one of the things that i buyers were
doing was they were buying homes
that they really didn't understand
in other words
let's say a home
had noise at night because it was near
i don't know a construction site and all
the trucks came back
they might send an eye buyer out there
that person might sell it to you and
there was negative signaling
in a market that is so vibrant like
today with low interest rates
home buyers are going to go look at 20
different homes put offers in on three
and visit the top three homes three four
five times talk to the neighbors
do their research
i buyers maybe they weren't doing this
kind of research they send out an
inspector inspector says the house looks
okay they don't know that the people
next door are renting in an airbnb or
that the people two doors down are
maniacs who play you know heavy metal
all night long or throw parties
constantly
that's something that a local real
estate broker and listen hey i
i think real real estate brokers get
paid like huge commissions and i'm not
crazy about that especially on the
higher end homes
but to their defense they do know which
houses are dogs in the market
so there's a data advantage for redfin
open door and zillow but they might not
have the qualitative things so that's
what i heard on the back end and i don't
think that that kind of news is out
there and i don't know that that's
specifically true but i suspect that has
something to do with this because if the
home was super high quality it's the
it's on the end of a cul-de-sac it has a
great view
i don't know the lot's flat all of that
put together would make for a more
educated buy right
and then maybe zillow became the buyer
of last resort we see something similar
in negative signaling uh in venture
capital
you go to the top firms they all say no
you go to the second tier firms they all
say no some new firm
uh meets the company they don't have the
reputation yet they take a chance on a
new firm
that the other firms passed on or a new
business model and that could either
work out for them but in most cases it
wouldn't and that's why reputation
matters and inside information matters
and network matters all of those things
add up to better decision making so
perhaps the issue here is zillow made
bad decisions they
thought through data that they would
know because if there's estimates you
know they can always tell you the value
of homes
and so
in a 2006 uh zillow blog post when they
talked about zestimates and i've had uh
the marketing the cmo from zillow on the
podcast previously and she talked about
uh zestimates that was very
controversial remember when that first
came out where they used taxes and sales
data to try to figure out how much your
house was home well maybe they got ahead
of their skis here maybe they were too
confident that they could make these
decisions
so you know for the first 13 years they
were a marketplace and they just did
legion right when you see brokers on the
website it says book this house with his
broker that's not the broker
representing the house that's somebody
who paid for that placement
and if they get that person a new client
who's interested in the home
they get uh paid for legion and i don't
know what it costs per
uh legion but i'm thinking it's tens of
dollars a pretty good business
do you want to increase your online
security well don't we all
if so you need to hear about nordvpn
nordvpn offers a vpn that stands for
virtual private network with benefits
such as helping customers stay safe
online and you get to access content
from over 59 different countries by
changing your virtual location with just
one click and you're never going to miss
your favorite show again
this keeps you safe while using public
wi-fi which can be a gold mine for
hackers i tell you this because i have
sensitive information i use nordvpn to
protect myself anytime my phone my ipad
my laptop my chromebook is out on the
road i need to protect myself and i was
in italy the girls wanted to watch
something on disney plus it was like we
don't have disney plus in italy ah boom
put my vp on on we're back in the game
nordvpn has an amazing cyber month deal
for my listeners twist listeners it's
amazing how affordable vpns are you can
now get in the united states i kid you
not nordvpn for about three dollars a
month go to
nordnordvpn.com twist or use the code
twist at checkout and you're gonna get i
kid you not 73 off your two year plan
plus a bonus gift just buy the two-year
plan this way you don't have to worry
about it you need to be safe and nordvpn
is how you're going to do that
nordvpn.com twist
[Music]